[Music]
second hour rotc thank you for staying
with us guys uh over on rumble and on
odyssey and because you know youtube
hates us uh but thank you for staying
with us we have a very special guest
marcia if you would introduce him uh yes
ladies and gentlemen he is a very very
well-known uh ufc fighter and uh
now sort of a a bit of a [ __ ] stirrer on
the internet i love it um yeah super
based tough guy jake shields what's up
jake how you doing on the show hey
thanks for having me guys what's going
on man bro really appreciate you being
on man i really i really really don't
know how busy you are
yeah squeezing it in between uh gotta go
training through my fighters right now
let's get it in real quick yeah sorry
man last week we're gonna do it i had to
go to the vet so yeah it was a whole
thing oh it's all good but but my
schedule gets so busy so it didn't
bother me bro i can't even imagine i
gotta tell you i'm sure you're going a
bunch of places and you talk about all
the mma stuff but dude lately you have
been
politically just on fire on twitter it's
been it's been so fun to watch can i say
all so funny though oh yeah very funny
because when i when i still had twitter
i actually before i lost my last twitter
yeah um he popped up in the replies
because stein said something and then
you say yeah everybody just turned it
into a car because i was talking about
my weight loss stuff
you want to take molly or yeah no jake
shields recommended meth and then i was
like well maybe molly and he was like i
mean molly will help you like get girls
and have fun
for weight loss yeah i like to just mess
around and have a good time on twitter
people get uh get way too serious and
offended and i'm just like [ __ ] them
like go out there and have fun and and
mess around and have a good time and you
know you get all the haters but the
reality the haters don't really exist in
the real world no one ever comes up give
me hey the dudes that are hating on
twitter they'll see me and they'll run
up like hey bro can i get a picture so
it's it's not real hey yeah well look
first off i wouldn't say any [ __ ] to you
to your face sir without their respect
i've seen your fights i would be very
worried i would say ship on your back
and when you turned around i'd point to
royce and no i don't want to get beat up
i don't want to get beat up because of
you i tell him all the time to stop
running his mouth
yeah i think as these guys do i thought
if you guys almost get the friends in
fights
have you noticed though there's a theme
in like because i noticed there's a
bunch of dudes from your uh you know
your line of work
that tend to lean a certain way yep and
uh is that do you notice that there
seems to be a trend among like people
that actually like get up maybe and go
out and exercise and like have like
creative hobbies and like you know do
constructive things that they tend to
lean
a certain way on the political spectrum
i think fighting too it's you know you
have to hold yourself self-accountable
to be successful so there's no more
there's nothing more serious and hard
training than fighting it was
interesting because politics were never
really involved in fighting over the
last year things kind of got forced on
us yeah so it was kind of nice to see
the majority of fighters think uh very
similar to all i do and if they don't
they accept other people's views no one
like hates each other having different
opinions like there's some great
fighters where i have different opinions
on them on things but we can still get
along it's not this weird like woke like
oh screw this guy he thinks different to
me and it's uh it's refreshing the
fighting the fighters aren't that way
and also no one was really scared to
cope with maybe a few guys the first
couple weeks but after like a month i
think everyone snapped out of it and
realized it was a big con
oh yeah the covet thing is has got to be
one of the one of the funniest things
uh where they're telling basically super
athletes you have to be careful i'm like
they're fine yeah they're gonna be fine
exactly was there anything more based
than just watching like supercuts of
specifically ufc fighters whenever they
would try to like do a gotcha yeah be
like what about covet or trump and
they'd be like yeah dude i don't really
care about that right now like i got a
fight coming up exactly yeah okay it is
what it is dude you gotta get locked in
a cage and fight one of the best
fighters in the world in front of
millions of people you think you give a
[ __ ] about covid yeah yeah you know it's
funny because i think a lot of fight
fans also tend to be a little bit more
based too like when desantis showed up
at like that fight and it was just
standing ovation like yeah i was rule
and i i think i think it's funny because
i think they always try to be like these
meat heads and i'm like are you kidding
me man some of the first off funniest
people online are
you people like you that are out there
and they know funniest interviews
funniest like you know what i mean press
conferences
but it's
surprisingly fighters are much uh much
smarter than people give us credit for
us it's really surprising that how many
intelligent fighters are out there yeah
you know how you know how i this is this
is funny because i just saw this article
a couple days ago and you know how i
know that you're bugging people in the
good way and you know the most time to
hit pieces against me bro this business
insider hit piece had to be one of the
funniest things i never think i saw this
one okay
have you have you have you gotten a call
from dave portnoy yet okay hey bro don't
[ __ ] worry about these [ __ ] bro
they do [ __ ] all the time
i get hit pieces all the time now it's
hilarious what's this one so this one is
prominent mma fighter mma fighters
denounce the fbi's radar mar-a-lago and
echo you're gonna love the title echo
right-wing talking points to defend
trump
now i follow you on twitter and the one
thing i'll tell you is you're not out
there defending trump you're just oh i'm
not even yeah i've never been a big
trump guy like you know i voted for
biden but i'm never a huge trump fan i
would like to see someone else run but
like the way they go after him it's
making me almost want to vote for him
again it's just so absurd so ridiculous
it's just you know they've raided
everyone they've made multiple fake uh
fake investigations this you know the
fbi is the same people that created the
russiagate hoax and now they're out
there raiding them they won't tell us
why and they expect us just to be like
oh yeah it's good i mean yeah of course
there's a slight chance it's not illegal
but it seems very unlikely and they just
accused them of things so many times and
it was fake because we don't trust at
this point it seems like they became
just a political wing of the you know of
the corporations the democratic party
and i think you know i doubt they will
but republicans had any backbone they
would start trying to completely defund
and dismantle the fbi when they take
power it's funny because we were just
watching a video with anthony sabatini
who's running for florida congress who
said the same thing which is like we
need we need to we florida he actually
he went further he says
florida should should not should kick
the fbi to florida not recognize him do
not recognize him we don't need to
follow you we have our own law
enforcement and get him out of here and
i think that's true because it's exactly
what we said on this show too like i
think trump let us down a lot especially
the last year to two years because
especially with the covet stuff he could
have gotten rid of fauci he you know he
agreed he agreed to the lockdowns that
really uh i think it was a bad idea but
him going along with it it just showed
uh yeah maybe lose some respect for him
yeah with that and then also the whole
like we're going to send the military to
shoot
to shoot people with tranquilizer
regards to the vaccine because it's so
great i'm like bro you are barking up
the wrong tree and
and and i think that's a reason but it's
the same thing that happened to me like
i'm i'm i'm more of a i'm a desantis
dude man i live in florida like he's
awesome yeah you know like you know and
again it's one of those things merch and
i talk about all the time we're like god
we want him four more years as our
governor but also like if the options
are what what are the options you know
if
honestly if they purple up trump and and
they try to make it so he can't run up
to my opinion to santa's the only other
option yeah yeah i mean desantos i mean
i like rand paul too but he doesn't
really gain traction with the masses so
i don't think he would win even though i
personally like rand paul rand paul's
rand paul is one of the greatest minds
out of anybody in the senate the problem
is is that he's like five foot three and
he's like he's like a wispy little man
and he's just not he doesn't have that
like you know unfortunately we're very
shallow society and the reason we voted
for certain guys is because it's like oh
like george w bush is the best example
ever right the guy was pretty much like
a slightly below average intelligent war
criminal right but because he was like
standing with the cowboy hat and the
rubble and he was like we're gonna hate
us for our freedoms we were like yeah
god damn it cowboy hats and toby keith
let's [ __ ] kill let's glass these
mozzies and everybody got all whipped
into a frenzy
that'd be fun but then it turns out he's
a not very intelligent worker
yeah he's like not a good dude but yeah
he just was that guy that you're like
[ __ ] yeah i'd have a beer with bush like
same with obama like obama did
probably you know by a lot of people i
mean my opinion is that he was the first
one to really start the racial like
starting the cracks in the dam with the
racial stuff but like obama seems like a
dude that if he you were on it not on
his [ __ ] list and you were having a beer
with him oh you'd be like that i had to
be with obama that's pretty [ __ ] cool
but then you kind of go don't don't
don't fall for that don't do not fall
for that [ __ ]
and bib's the guy no one wants to be
around
dude he's the guy afterwards everyone
she's trying to talk to everyone they're
walking away from out of here but it's
funny though because this is a
verifiably true and i thought it was a
joke but fauci finally admitted to it
during the aids
epidemic he used to go to gay clubs this
is true this isn't a joke he used to go
to gay clubs to see
why it was i got to investigate the
toilet seats
and you see all the gay origins
oh the thing is i need to watch it's all
it's for science
just standing there sipping a [ __ ]
like a green apple martini i have to
watch it's for science
well something a lot of people don't
know about the aids epidemic too he was
pushing um azt large amounts a bit early
on and it was causing lots of gay men to
die it was speeding up their deaths once
they cut the azt back and hardly use it
and give really small dosages you notice
guys with hiv aren't really dropping
dead anymore they're living a long time
so bauchi was poisoning these guys i had
a cousin who had aids and he uh he was
doing fine they put him on
azt then he was sick and died within a
few months
this was all pushed by fauci selling
drugs i mean they're used they're wiped
from the internet man but if you look if
you look like you know archives of
newspapers and stuff the gay community
used to hate fauci they hated him
because he was he was also which is now
just fragile's been wrong a lot he's
like jim cramer um fauci is another one
that he he he was another one that that
implied that if you just live in the
same household as someone with hiv
you'll get it and it was of course not
true
yeah so he had us scared of like you
know i said i was young had a gay cousin
with eight so i hear that from like
bouchy i'm like scared of my own cousin
who we're good friends and i'm like
scared to be around him when i'm hearing
like oh you can get aids from being
around them so it's terrible the
you know i still was wrong my cousin's
son but he said different i mean i
probably wasn't as close to him after
that because he had me all scared and
it's terrible you know that he did that
i'm sure he broke up so many
relationships and family and had people
scared of their uh their loved ones and
he was putting them on azt on top of it
it's exactly what he did with covet he
had people afraid of their family
members families broke up and they put
people on a drug that's not tested
yeah i often wonder too with my uncle
because my uncle died of aids and uh
he
same thing by the way like my when my
dad found out my uncle was going to be
staying with us he had a [ __ ]
meltdown yeah and my mom's like he's not
a [ __ ] child molester or anything he
just yeah he just used to party with
bikers and he did some iv drugs like
relax but then it was like well you're
living in the same house and i know he
like cooks meals there and what if he
like cuts himself during like while he's
cooking and my mom's like i'm pretty
sure if if gerard cuts himself cooking
he's gonna throw everything out because
he's a pretty precaution i don't think
he's gonna go no that's fine you know
what i mean but it became and then he
died like he got clean he turned his
life around he was very healthy and he
just [ __ ] died and it was in the that
time right there in the early to mid 90s
where it's like they were probably
pumping them they were vouchers no this
is true though you're right like you're
saying too that was scared of our own
family like it's so terrible they did
that they did the same thing with i had
you know not close family members but
distant relatives not wanting to be
around me so my family because we
weren't backs and like my baby's mom
being crazy trying to tell me i couldn't
be around my daughter it's like no
that's that's not gonna happen it's uh
trying to divide families and people
it's uh complete madness could you
imagine being in his family and being
like look i want my kids to be healthy
keep them away from jake yeah the super
actually
keep away from the super athlete who i
knew i need my 25 pound overweight 11
year old all right away from him
because i don't want him
you know
so jake i follow you and i'm assuming
that you're pretty much a libertarian at
heart right i mean that would be yeah i
guess okay i'm gonna get called
conservative but i don't really you know
i'm not really conservative i'm more in
line with the conservatives because they
can accept it be having a different view
they're like okay you know you you think
different than me
not all the liberals obviously but
there's a portion of them that like wish
me to die because i think different
about some things
yeah man i can't i can't even imagine so
it's funny because merch and i were both
ron paul 2012 guys obviously i mean ron
paul is great and all that stuff and i
think a lot of people have been pushed
over to this side because
to the right to the right wing side i
mean because of like okay but at least i
could see what i want over here that
that's the biggest thing it's like i
could dude the fact that i just saw
tulsi gabbard host for tucker carlson
blew my mind i'm like don't [ __ ] talk
about republicans being this or that
like at the [ __ ] end of the day yeah
okay fine we don't agree with you gives
a [ __ ] but you know what who you voting
for lower taxes that's fine i don't care
welcome aboard
for us it's like it's me it's like that
it's like now they hired 87 000 irs
agents who some of them are going to be
[ __ ] armed
absolutely insanity that's another thing
that republicans have any backbone they
would instantly try to repeal this all
these extra irs agents like they're not
going to there's already enough agents
to tax the rich people same tax the rich
this is for your 600 bedmo transactions
and whatnot that's it dude it's exactly
right and then you know and then and
then they pass that but we're not going
to raise taxes on anybody and they go
well you're making forty thousand
dollars or more you're going to raise
your taxes but
inflation you're like barely surviving
you're not living anywhere dude and it's
it's it's pretty funny to me that we we
are we are at this point and it kind of
feels like and maybe i'm wrong that
they're trying to rush as much as they
can because the inevitable that's going
to happen in 2022 i think they're trying
to push as much as they can that's why
they're terrified of trump too that's
the other reason they're terrified of
him because like the guy or hate the guy
the guy's endorsement means something
and they want to discredit him and it's
not going to work yeah yeah it's clear
he's a real threat to you know the deep
state people that run things you know
they even called them like trump
supporters terrorist threats and like
the way they've gone after him so even
though i don't think trump's the best
leader i think he has some great ideas
in his you know anti-globalism i think
that's what scares them you know
mentioning things like hey maybe we
don't need to be in nato and stuff like
that just freaks them out see this is
this is this is third in line for the
presidency while you're looking at the
screen by the way
and look who's second in line
oh you oh sorry i'm sorry you you mean
montel williams side piece yeah i know
yeah right yeah and uh willie brown
mayor of um san francisco he gave his
first job basically i think he even said
it was basically gave her the job
because she was doing blow jobs hey man
oh job's a job but it is it is true
she's the only person more hated in the
government than biden and i think it's
hilarious she's despised she's despised
by our own staffers yeah yeah he makes
it so we're like well i hope he gets
through
also the whole biden around the country
like they say we're crazy conspiracy
theories but look at this it's very
clear this guy is no possible way
running the country so it makes you be
like who is running our country because
biden just kind of mumbles around try
shaking hands with people that aren't
there reads reads repeat the line the
guy the guy is a clown and we act like
he's the president of the u.s that's
just obviously not true but i
couldn't run a wendy's
so serious exactly i think i think
marsha and i have a theory that it's
obama and the only reason why is we did
catch an interview he did a couple about
a year and a half ago where he said my
he go if you could they asked him if you
could run for a third term would you and
he goes well only if i could sit around
in my sweatpants and have an earpiece
and tell somebody what to do he really
said that that's for real and then biden
wins then you're like is that what's
happening because it kind of feels like
that's what's happening yeah it feels
like some someone's telling them what to
do and i don't know if it's obama
because someone might have been telling
obama what to do too it could be you
know he said it gets complicated to know
who's doing it but you can see he he's
not the one in charge and early on
they'd you know you could watch the
media machine early on i think earlier
they pushed kamala yeah she just didn't
catch then they switched to like pete he
didn't catch so then it was like a
last-ditch effort but the media switched
to pushing uh to push by you just watch
it in real time with who they're pushing
who they're against and it shows you
that it's like uh like they have people
picked it would be funny to have pete
putin be the president but it's but
instead of biden catching cover he kept
catching monkey pucks over and over
again that'd be pretty funny
that'd be entertaining i just wish these
[ __ ] would get it together it's like
push whatever [ __ ] policies you want
down my throat but could we have at
least been able to look at tulsi gabbard
for the next four years yeah like if she
if you're gonna have [ __ ] 15 for 20
inflation and gas prices skyrocketing
and [ __ ] riots in the streets and
warfare i would be like can i at least
get tulsi gabbard on the tv you're
telling me i'll take it yeah like maybe
every morning doing squats while she's
telling you like guys remember today
she was a congressman yeah woman
congresswoman okay well fair enough man
every day and then now they're did you
see today they're cheering on
the inflation didn't get higher
but it didn't get lower yeah exactly you
know i missed that today but it's
ridiculous to keep acting like oh we're
doing a good job oh gas prices fell down
like
to to only two dollars more than they
were a year ago so give me a break
that's not a win i'm sorry i'm sorry
jake you don't have three teslas
i got one yeah
the supercharger prices they jacked up
too elon musk knocked that in oh dude
it's so funny you brought that up
somebody else was telling me that like
the car comes with that but you have to
pay an extra service description sir dlc
well sometimes you charge hold on but
there's a superchargers you charge it
and i right i don't really pay attention
because it was cheaper i looked at my
supercharger the other day and i'm like
wait this is like as much as gas now so
he's like and i googled it up and i
guess you jumped the prices up like kind
of secretly so what's gonna happen we
all have electric cars i mean i like
elon musk but do you want elon musk
deciding what we pay to drive no of
course not these oil companies there's
multiple different companies multiple
different countries there's a little bit
of competition if it's elon musk you
know deciding he can literally charge
whatever he wants and andy on top of
that is like bro you we were talking
about it yesterday you've seen the
backups at the charging stations in
california where like people are waiting
five hours to [ __ ] just for what they
have now if they switch what do they say
they want every car by 2040 i think they
were saying to be electric first of all
that's not gonna happen but if if they
were to do that right now california has
to have scheduled blackouts because they
don't have enough power if everybody has
which by the way they pointed out that
charging an electric car uses as much
energy as running four ac three ac three
air conditioners which is fine but now
all you're gonna have is you're gonna
have rolling blackouts because all they
have is stupid green energy over there
and then we know what's going to happen
we're going to be buying power from
canada or something that's going to be
the next thing that's going to happen
yeah when they try to force things
generally doesn't work and it's uh it
doesn't make sense they're overpushing
electric car who knows you know maybe
it's because they can turn your electric
car off well they don't want it oh you
can't drive these days we're having
climate problems they can they can shut
your car off whenever which is why i
still have a gas car i mean i'm not
going to have just an electric car shut
off when they want they also track
everywhere you drive that imagine that
imagine jake they go sorry you're
suspended on twitter you can't drive
your tesla for 12 hours yeah but the
problem is even modern even modern
gas-powered cars can do that like they
hack it to your car now well new ones
yeah
yeah there's uh if you ever get a chance
looking look into this guy michael
hastings he was a journalist that was i
swallowed i swear to god my hand to god
he was
finishing up and it just put out a story
about how the cia can hack into your
cars like computers now
and make them do things
and then like a week later he died
driving his mercedes mysteriously in a
car crash that was described as him
driving into a guardrail at full speed
without ever hitting the brakes which is
an odd yeah
sounds like they want to make a
statement oh you're going to call us out
here you go yeah it was very weird what
about the dude that's that that was
figuring out how to power a car with
water that guy died too they just had a
new guy that did that and he died
that guy uvaldi died he had a gas
powered uh the water power car he was
worried stan meyer had the water powered
car back in the day and then remember
they were like oh he wanted he went to
all these meetings with people and then
he went out to this dinner one night and
he got poisoned at dinner and then there
was no
only was he investigation bad food he
said i remember he said i was poisoned
and then he collapsed and died and they
were like well nothing more to see here
yeah yeah no big deal yeah no it doesn't
seem like um electric cars have anything
to do with helping the environment it
seems like it's just a way of uh to add
control and give these people more power
people pushing it are the absolute worst
people in the world that's what has to
be skeptical evil i i mean a lot of
people could but i think it's evil i
think the word is evil and i don't think
i think that sometimes
a lot some people overdo it sometimes i
think some people go like they're
literal demons they're not literal
demons i i think they are
evil people we've always had evil people
and we have evil people
when you read which is why they've
always said demons and angels because
some people have always been evil and
you know whether you're not religious
it's just the way some people are evil
some people are good yeah people want to
be like hey what's what's causing people
to be evil so you can blame it on demons
whether they're real or not i have no
idea but it's uh it's that evil uh way
of thinking
well jake i know i know you said you had
a heart out so i guess thank you so much
for coming on man that was a lot of fun
we'll do it again sometime in the future
you you are welcome on the show whatever
you want bro this this was this was a
lot of fun congrats on the hit piece yes
congratulations
i'm getting them all the time now it's
the funny part i miss something it's the
same guy that wrote the one about
portnoy so congratulations yeah you're
making it
it was funny when i was uh what proof
some girl managed like oh i i looked
your thing and it's like it says you're
a conspiracy theorist
misogynist and uh
and and aids denial or something like so
like oh these are people i'm like this
guy yeah this guy's awesome he sounds
interesting that should be on your
tinder bio
on the sb splc hates me i'm i'm a
conspiracy not that would be hilarious
[ __ ] man misogynist
everything anything you want anything
you want anyone to plug man now that you
need our help but
i know just you know uh twitter twitter
jake shields aj jakes jill's instagram i
got my clothing company uh american
jujitsu at americanfight.com and um
that's all i can think of right now just
thanks for all the support throughout
the years awesome brother man thank you
so much but we really do appreciate it
thank you so much dude have a good one
guys have a great day take it easy
that's cool man he's awesome dude he's a
[ __ ] good dude
that was a lot of fun very laid back
very chill uh
that guy
look follow me can he trade me to kill
people with my hands you think
you can't eat a steak then though